MLB Network analyst Sports Illustrated
senior baseball writer also baseball on
Fox
how would you recap the last 72 hours
Tom in baseball wild I'm talking about -
I call them the most compelling players
available on the planet talking about so
hey Otani and Giancarlo Stanton Lord of
the angels and the Yankees
I mean players like this are marquee
names that just don't become available
and they did one wound up in LA and I
called Anaheim but LA and the other
wound up in New York you know it's
seismic in terms of the impact these
guys can make but if you're the
commissioner Rob Manfred and you look at
this deal that the Yankees and Marlins
pulled off is there any trepidation
hesitation on your part as the
Commissioner baseball to look at this
and say yep I'm fine with this going
through he's fine way that I could tell
you that everybody in baseball is fine
with this because the Yankees are back
you know last year there were a nice
story got within one game of the World
Series Aaron Judge one of the most
popular players and all of the land and
they just got bigger and better and
they're like no Yankees now they're easy
to love and probably easier to hate
because they're so darn good they're
gonna be like Jordans Bowl they're gonna
be like the Beatles I'm just talking
about as they travel around on the road
as the number one attraction in baseball
okay is it good for I know that we love
the big market teams getting these
players but this is Florida with another
they usually clean house when they win a
World Series they're cleaning house they
didn't come close to winning a World
Series and what do you get in return
that's what I didn't understand why
didn't bet I feel I feel so sorry for
Marlins fan South Florida in general
because you know let's face it Jeffrey
Lurie the previous owner never really
reached out to them that never was a
bond between the team of community
because there were so many fire sales
now you're all excited about this new
ownership somebody make taken over your
favorite restaurant with new ownership
and they change the menu and not for the
better trading away John Carlos said and
as you said it was a salary dump it's
not as if they got anybody back that
they can be excited about today
I maybe even down the road so it was all
about them cutting payroll they're not
done yet
you know everything that those fans have
been through and they thought things
might change it's actually gonna get
worse for the next couple years because
now they owe it to the franchise to
really stripped at the ahta makes no
sense to try to get say a second
wild-card spot put together an 85 win
team yeah very bad for a long time we're
talking to Tom verducci's at the winter
baseball meetings in Orlando all right
tell me about Shohei Otani
and I thought he would go to an American
League team because he could deh on the
days he's not pitching explain the whole
phenomenon with him and why did he end
up with the Angels what you write about
the DA's I mean he hasn't played the
outfield in about four years on any kind
of regular base so I think even though
the agent set out saying you know he
didn't have specifics in mind there's no
doubt that geography west coast and big
ad8 had a lot to do with it so now
you're down to the Mariners and the
Angels for American League West Coast
teams angels make a lot of sense they'll
use him once a week of a starting
pitcher use them three times a week as a
th so outlook cool so you don't have to
sit or play some more first base which
he hasn't done the last two years
what Otani can be an all-star as a
hitter or as a pitcher I don't think
he's being all start doing both I think
it would be an impact starting pitcher
right away but making the transition as
a hitter and really a part time hitter
it's going to be extremely difficult for
him just in terms of physical recovery
aspect of pitching but I do think then
he everybody was on board with this guy
in terms of makeup athleticism talent I
compare him to Jacob degrom on the mound
yeah he think he's gonna be that good
that quickly whether he hits I think a
tiny will hit but there's definitely a
bigger upside on the mound why the
Angels well I mean listen the angels
haven't won a playoff game in eight
years they have more of the worst farm
system in baseball so it's not as if he
sat down and said which team is going to
be good for the next six years because
he's bound to this the team that he
signed with for six years I think it was
because he did prefer the West Coast
there's no doubt about that and he's
been wired eh and you don't listen Mike
Trout got on the phone and they think
face time time the meeting you know
Buster Posey was in the room for the
Giants right there isn't really
everybody was you know they made videos
of star players saying we want you he
said he felt a connection to the Angels
I think it was because it's Southern
California and it's the ability to be
aged the National League teams they just
did not make any sense I saw this from
Buster Olney here and well there's some
stuff going on behind the scenes that
the commissioners attention has been on
this topic it's been unprecedented a
team executive told Buster Olney but
they want to know if there was any quid
pro quo promises outside of the rules in
recruiting Otani because you only had a
certain amount of money that you could
give him but they're warned I guess
teams were warned against discussing
future contracts and business
relationships and against third-party
imaginations paying off someone who
might have had influence with Otani
hikes yeah and these warnings that out
there for a year everybody knew that
Otani was coming if he waited two years
at the age of 25 based on the new rules
he was a total free agent no
restrictions on the amount of money he
probably gets 200 million dollars so now
the most he could get was a little over
three million dollars the guy's given up
almost two hundred million dollars to
come two years early so naturally the
inclination was I mean this is so bad
this is like college recruiting you know
you sign with the school that offers you
the best deal and I mean a deal and
there was some thought that a team could
say listen we know you're geared up a
lot of money but as soon as you sign
here we've got an extension in our
pocket to give you that 200 million well
that's against the rules and you saw
that the Commissioner just banned for
life John Capel Ella the brave GM and
that was in terms of skirting the rules
and international free agents and I
think that was a shot across the bow to
everything to say we're watching you
closely and that got everybody's
attention because that penalty was a lot
more severe than people thought and
whether it was coincident or not I do
think it's served as a warning with how
close dealt with Oh Connie have fun at
the meetings Tom we appreciate your time
as always that's Tom Verducci great
baseball writer broadcaster for major
league baseball network and MLB on Fox
for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app